how many crafty ways could there
possibly be to use a hot glue gun well
if you're willing to get creative there
are actually quite a few so if you've
ever wondered how to customize your very
own phone case make sure to stick around
until the end of the video don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this and give this video a
big thumbs up now join us as we take a
look at 10 hot glue gun life hacks for
crafting non-slip clothes hanger we've
all been there
you get home after a long day of hanging
out with friends and all you want to do
is hang up your clothes and sit down to
watch your favorite television show you
take off your coat grab a hanger and try
to hang it up then what happens that
coat just slips right off onto the floor
so frustrating well if you've ever
experienced this headache
we've got just the solution for you way
out there in the deep interwebs some
genius has figured out a way to use a
hot glue gun to make completely non-slip
clothes hangers hallelujah
you'd be surprised how incredibly simple
these things are to make at home all you
need is clothes hangers a hot glue gun
and some glue to get started make sure
the glue is nice and hot
from there grab your favorite clothes
hanger and grip it firmly at one end
moving slowly trace a wiggle of hot glue
down one side of the hanger where the
shoulder of your coat would sit once the
glue on the first side is dried repeat
the same procedure on the other side
once the entire hanger is dried the
project is complete from there you're
free to hang up shirts dresses and even
vests without worrying about them
constantly slipping off we got to give
it up to whoever came up with this one
vintage wax seals before the modern
stamp became widely used personalized
wax stamps were all the rage
it's exciting to imagine many of the
famous writers throughout history
sealing up a letter with hot wax waiting
for it to cool and then shipping it off
to whoever it was addressed to can't you
just see Thomas Jefferson pouring the
wax and anxiously waiting for it to be
ready to send thanks to one crafty
person anyone with a hot glue gun and
some crayons can now enjoy this timeless
tradition in their own home the method
for making these wax stamps could not be
simpler the first thing you have to do
is write someone a letter it could be
anyone
maybe you could send a letter to your
mom thanking her for your last birthday
present Orson once your sibling to tell
them you love them no matter who you
write the letter to once that step is
done you are ready to move on to
creating a wicked seal to get started
gather your favorite color crayons and
peel off all their paper wrappings
hot tip alert it's smart to have a
dedicated hot glue gun just for crayons
as things can definitely get a little
messy
once the crayons are unwrapped slowly
feed one into the hot glue gun and wait
for it to melt once it's melted squeeze
out a small dollop onto the back of your
envelope and wait for it to cool once
it's cooled you're good to go
awesome vase designs when springtime
comes and all the prettiest flowers are
in bloom it's almost impossible to
resist picking a few and bringing them
home go ahead and pick some it's not a
crime
grab some ranunculus or some amaranth
and bring them home with you and when
you do you have to make sure you have an
awesome base to do those flowers justice
the good news is is that you don't have
to go out and buy some super expensive
vase to have a nice container for your
new floral friends in fact all you need
is a nice looking glass a hot glue gun
and some glue to get started insert the
glue stick into the glue gun and give it
a moment to melt once the glue is all
hot and ready you can begin to make your
awesome base design it's helpful to do
this with a friend but it's definitely
possible to do on your own to holding
your container in one hand and the glue
gun in the other
start making thin lines around the
outside of the glass we like to start at
the bottom of the glass and spiral
upwards but feel free to experiment and
see what works for you
once you've spiraled your way around the
outside of the entire glass make sure to
let it cool in a safe place once the
glue is dried you've got yourself a
beautiful container for your pretty
flowers no sew TP when you're having a
sleepover with friends or just hanging
out around the house there's nothing
better than having a cool place to chill
with this in mind one DIY blog came up
with a pretty inventive way to make the
perfect teepee to impress guests as a
little heads up this crafting project is
probably better suited for people with a
little bit of experience as the process
is a little involved the materials
however are readily available and very
easy to find to make your teepee begin
by finding several wooden poles your
favorite fabric twine and a loaded hot
glue gun next bundle all the wooden
poles at one end and secure them
together with twine make sure you tie it
tight
once all the poles are together you're
ready to start designing the outside of
the teepee with your favorite fabric
this is your chance to personalize your
hangout spot so don't be afraid to get
creative once you've selected your cloth
begin wrapping them around the wooden
frame of your teepee securing it often
using your hot glue gun the cloth should
run along the entire structure but don't
forget to leave a little opening to get
inside once you've added all the fabric
you're ready to invite some friends over
and put
TP to good use colorful wintertime
snowflakes everyone has their own
personal favorite wintertime activity
some people like to listen to jazz and
enjoy a nice cup of hot chocolate while
others would prefer to get out and shred
the slopes on their snowboard no matter
what your preference when the cold
winter months roll around the chilly
weather brings with it a perfect excuse
to start a new crafting project and what
better way to bring in the snowy months
than with some colorful and homemade
snowflake decorations this project is
almost too simple and the only materials
you need to get started are parchment
paper a hot glue gun glue and nail
polish the first step in making these
incredible snowflakes is to lay out a
nice sheet of parchment paper to work on
once the glue has melted inside of the
gun you could begin to trace your shapes
start with the long lines at the
snowflake first making six equal lines
that join together at the center from
there you can start to add those small
little details that make each snowflake
their own work of art for the easiest
route trace three little lines on each
end of the six main lines to form a
neatly flight pattern once your
snowflakes have dried peel them off of
the parchment paper and paint both sides
with your favorite nail polish talk
about the perfect winter activity office
chair makeover office chairs can
sometimes be pretty boring or even
downright ugly it makes sense that these
rolling seats would be run-of-the-mill
since most people are just sitting in
them to use the computer but if you're
spending so much time sitting in it why
not personalize your chair and make it
extra cool and even when you've already
got a cool office chair sometimes the
fabric eventually needs to be replaced
well no matter what the case if you're
looking to update your office chair
we've got just the life hack for you to
begin all you'll need is an office chair
your favorite fabric a pair of scissors
and a loaded hot glue gun start by
carefully removing the fabric currently
on the chair which can usually be done
by removing whatever frame is holding it
in place next lay the old fabric over
the new one and cut out the new cloths
to the same size once you've got your
new fabric all cut and ready simply
place it on the chair and tuck the
excess into the back now it's time to
tackle the seat of the chair
once you've unscrewed the seat and cut
the new fabric down to size you're ready
to grab your hot glue gun stretch your
new fabric over the seat and then fold
and fasten the leftover cloths to the
bottom of the seat with hot glue once
the hot glue has set reassemble all the
pieces and just watch how jealous
everyone is DIY welcome sign when you're
going someplace you haven't been before
it's easy to get lost we've all been
there you head to a friend's
neighborhood and when you get there you
just can't tell which how
there's tough luck well worry no more
because one incredible DIY blog has come
up with the perfect solution if you
never want your friends to get lost
again you've got to make your own
personalized welcome sign beyond making
your house easier to find nothing says
hello and a very warm welcome like a
homemade welcome sign made with true
love and care although you'll need to
purchase a few special materials the
method for making these signs is as
simple as pie to get started make sure
you've got a few gold melting sticks a
piece of wood a glue gun and parchment
paper or a silicon mat to draw your
designs on next load your melting sticks
into your glue gun and allow them to
melt completely while they're melting
you can start thinking about what
message you want to write on your sign
something as simple as hello and welcome
to my house works great but you could
also do something more elaborate or
maybe even an inside joke no matter what
you're going to write the next step is
to trace the words onto your parchment
paper or silicone mat once your words
have cooked adhere them to your piece of
wood using the same glue you wrote with
make sure you put it somewhere that your
friends can see homemade earrings
there's not many things cooler than
having a ton of friends but having a lot
of friends comes with its own burden
having to buy different presents for
constant birthday parties with that in
mind we've found the perfect low-cost
present that will save you cash and
occupy your time can you say homemade
earrings we sure can and you won't
believe how straightforward these
special little things are to make the
first step is to gather all of your
materials a hot glue gun loaded with
glue gold spray paint a silicone mat
acrylic paint and the hooks for your
earrings with your silicone mat laid out
in front of you the next step is to
start creating your pattern we suggest a
circular pattern which you can make by
squeezing several dots of glue
side-by-side in a round shape on your
mat once the dots have cooled completely
grab your favorite acrylic paint and
carefully color each dot with it once
the paint dries carefully flip the
circles over and spray the back side
with your gold spray paint what the
spray paint is drying grab your earring
hooks and make sure your hot glue gun is
full of hot glue next carefully glue
your hooks to the gold side of your
earring design and allow to cool
completely wrap these little gems up in
some nice paper and get ready to blow
your friends mind with an incredible
gift non-slip shoes have you ever been
walking down the street minding your own
business when all of a sudden you slip
and drop all the fruit you were carrying
oh brother there is nothing worse than
wasting a bunch of fresh and delicious
products well if you've ever been in
this situation before you'll be
absolutely delighted to know that we
an amazing solution that's right when
top-notch blog has created the ultimate
life hack to turn slippery shoes into
non-slip shoes this crafting project
could not be any easier and all you need
to get started is a pair of shoes a hot
glue gun and glue a quick pro tip for
all you sleepyheads out there this trick
works super well with you around the
house slippers once you've got your
shoes ready and your hot glue gun loaded
and heated with glue the first step is
to simply flip the shoes upside down to
the bottom of the shoe is facing towards
you next it's important to take a few
minutes to think about the design you
want to use on the bottom of the shoe
almost any design would do even
squiggles and straight lines but this is
also a great opportunity to show your
creativity you could use the glue to
draw a picture of your favorite pet or
you could even write your name once
you've got your design squeeze it out on
the bottom of each shoe and allow the
glue to cool completely from there
you're ready to move about the world
without having to constantly worry about
having an embarrassing slip customized
phone case nowadays it seems like
everyone has their very own smartphone
in fast-food restaurants and coffee
shops around the world it's not uncommon
to see even young children swiping left
and right and even taking selfies with
their friends with so many phones in the
world it's easy to feel like your
smartphone is getting lost in the crowd
and with the limited number of
smartphone cases out there it's pretty
common to accidentally mistake your own
phone for somebody else's worry no
longer because we've got the ultimate
hot glue gun life hack to solve this
problem before you begin it might be a
good idea to think a little bit about
how you want to represent your
personality through your custom phone
case
do you like food well maybe you can find
little bejeweled bananas to glue to your
case or if sports are your thing look
for some awesome football or hockey
shapes to use no matter what you choose
the only things you need to get started
or a phone case small objects that
represent your personality and a hot
glue gun filled with hot glue before you
dive into gluing anything on permanently
it's smart to layout the objects on your
case just to get a feel for what kind of
design you want to use once you've made
up your mind simply glue all of your
objects on to the outside of your phone
case and wait for them to dry once
everything is completely dry you've got
yourself an incredible personalized
phone case is there a different hot glue
gun life hack that you use at home let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]